and this is why when i got away with
that i figured i'd never get in trouble
again
that's why when i was sitting in that
[__] cell after i woke up from my
[__] cocaine
that the judge sentenced me i was blown
the [__] away like i was scared
i didn't know what to expect you know
when you get locked up and you go to
[__] prison you don't know what the
[__] to expect
i thought there was a possibility i was
gonna get locked up so i started boxing
and swimming
and running and you know what i'm saying
you know learning how to tighten your
ass on command
but prison was the most [__] up
experience in the world that i got so
much out of
and you guys look at me like joy what
the [__] are you talking about you know
i walked in there and there was a guy i
knew that had gotten arrested for drugs
in boulder and i went to him
before i got sentenced and he goes
listen no matter what happens when you
go to the prison
ask for this guy ed or whatever and then
tell them that you know me and they'll
take care of you you know
so i remember walking in like first you
go to a city jail and you wait till
county
until your bed opens up in prison and
they take you to diagnostic for two
weeks
and they [__] show you cards what do
you see
a machine gun and you know what i'm
saying and then they take your blood out
and then they send you to whatever
destination you're gonna go they decide
whether you had a job
you know whether you had a license at
the time of your arrest whatever the
[__]
so you know i was [__] scared and i
walked in and
people were yelling all [__] night
when you get there and
you have to take this like uh diagnostic
test and they put
brain waves on you and [__] and i
remember that i asked everybody like
what do they do that for and he goes
that goes for the feds like that they
have you on profile
and you can get that [__] but you have
to petition the court and stuff
i was really interested in what it said
and after about a month i ended up in my
destination which was it was a prison
camp called camp george west
and my counsel there was a redneck dude
that i really loved from mississippi or
something
and he he hated [__] spicks blacks
chinese he hated everybody
except white people or rednecks that's
it you know and he kind of liked me and
i would break his balls all the time you
know like
why am i here do this for me but it's
funny because when you walk in the
prison you don't know what to expect
like i thought i was just gonna lay in a
cell all day
they make you [__] work and they pick
a job for you like they don't give a
[__] what you did on the outside
like they'll just look at you and go
garbage and that's it but i was lucky i
had a license at the time of my arrest
plus i was going to college so when you
have a license in jail you're like god
but you have to work yourself up to the
ranks so at first they go mr yarber
they told me to tell people i had
meningitis they go when you report to
your camp tell them that you had the flu
or something they won't put you in the
kitchen
oh you have to have that [__] hepatitis
b
so i walk in i'm like i got hepatitis b
d
e g i got every [__] hep you got and
he's like i don't believe you kid
he looked at my thing and he put me in
the kitchen and he made me a baker
i had never even cooked before here i am
a [__] baker
so the first day my assignment was to
make cinnamon rolls like popping fresh
dough you know that [__]
they were this big when they came out of
the [__] oven
like i was supposed to make like 300 of
them i made like 18 of them they were
this [__] big
and they tried to cut them but they were
too [__] hard
so he's like nah forget i'm demoting you
as a baker
you've got your license you're in charge
of the stock clerk that was a sweet job
because you had your own
space and you could hide steroids and
weed and heroin and speed for people
and charge them rent come on
[__] i took that mentality
right in there i'm like really
plus you got to order the food so you
got to order your own food for you
so you could have your own little
[__] thing so prison wasn't really
that bad for me
you know but i started ordering food and
i would know what coming the food like
you know you guys are worried about pink
slime and your meat
[Laughter]
you know what you get in the meat in the
[__] prison you get bones and
fingernails
they don't give a [__] the fish is
disgusting everything the chicken is
like that 7-eleven chicken
it looks like they put the pieces
together on a bone and just
strung it up and on the way home tonight
get a chicken 11 7-eleven [__] wing
and
dissect it when you get home you'll see
the chickens not often the same the meat
it's all from different
those hindus they know what they're
doing they put those
they put those chicken wings back like a
puzzle you know what i'm saying
so it's just you know i i didn't know
what the [__] to do with this meet
i would i became friends with some of
the invics so i'll never forget that
they i would be in the back
like watching the food and it would be
chow time and my buddies
it was hysterical they'd come into the
thing and look at me like
and i couldn't tell them that their food
sucked so i would have to yell
don't do it
and they'd be like nah we don't want no
meat [__]
don't do it
so i was in charge of the kitchen let me
tell you something i had such a good
time in there
there was a black guy every 15 minutes
he'd just go freeze
and the whole place was jumping i'm just
[Laughter]
you know and i went in there and i made
a point not to do coke or nothing like
that i was like you know what they have
that population in there
people doing steroids i said i'm gonna
do this time the right way
and it was funny on thursday nights they
would have movie night
and on movie night the projector would
always break
so i would always be cracking jokes in
the daytime so they would go cuba
get up there and do some [__] time
this is in prison
so i would just go up there and goof on
the guards you know look at this
[__] with his [__] feet
uses those sneakers every day what the
[__] are you talking i just go up there
and talk
and every week i get them they go joey
go up there the projector's broken so i
do 20 minutes
and there was this guy that killed the
wife the dog
and the boyfriend and he was in charge
of the library real nice guy
from buffalo new york the guy didn't say
nothing he was one of those nerdy guys
or glasses that
was small but he [__] killed them and
took their hands and boiled them i mean
this guy was like a
and he had like 90 years and he wouldn't
talk to nobody he's white and [__]
and i remember one day he gave me a
notebook this [__] guy that killed
two people and a dog
gave me a notebook and he goes bro
there's a notebook she can write jokes
and i go what [__] jokes
he goes to jokes you do on thursday
night i don't do no jokes
i just talk and he goes whoa you just
[__] talk
he goes when you get out of here you
really gotta try comedy
you really gotta get into it he goes if
not i'm gonna escape and cut you the
[__] out
cut your hand and and here's this guy
that had no emotion and he
took time to tell me this [__] but it
gets better i went to that counselor at
mr blue
and i would break his balls and i say mr
blue tell me what's on my diagnostic i
want to know tell me
he's like you don't want to know you
don't want to know bug [__]
that's what he would call me bug [__]
and one day i finally bust him he goes
you want to know what's in your file
come on come with me
and we went here and there was no
computers then it was like four [__]
handwritten
and he took these hand type files and he
showed them to me there was all these
big words like psychiatry whatever
and i go what does that mean he goes
that if i wanted something
that if you wanted something and i had
it that i should give it to you because
you're going to get it anyway
you're going to steal it from me you'll
get it anyway
and i remember looking at him going go
[__] yourself you [__]
you know this is what you and i went
back to my room and i thought about it
for a day and
i was like you know this is all i am
ever going to be as a [__] common
thief you know
and i thought about what he was saying
to me and i was mad at him and one day i
went back and it came to me
he was telling me i could do whatever
the [__] i want in my life he just
worded it that way he goes you could do
whatever the [__] if i got something you
could do it and that's what he was
saying that you could get whatever you
want without doing this [__]
and i ran back one day and i go mr blue
i gotta talk to you about something i'm
not that mad at you
i understood where he was coming from he
looked at me he took a pause and he goes
good
he goes hopefully you'll never [__]
come back in here with your cuban
disgusting ass because he hated cubans
and even though i knew he ate the cubans
i knew he had a liking for me he had
respect for me
to say that he took the time to say that
to me you know it was just something
that i was like you know when i get out
of here
i have to turn my life around or i got
to do
smaller crimes
but that lesson that talk from him and
that [__] guy
was the reason why i'm on this [__]
stage sign so prison wasn't all that bad
because i got something out of it
oh and i got like there was an age unit
it was 1987. people hated people with
aids
the age unit was where all the food was
and the drugs and they and
and i got to hang out with aids guys
and i loved them and i shouldn't say
that but they were great i don't have
[__] hiv today
and nobody knew about it they wouldn't
let people talk with them they were had
them like [__]
orphans like the ugly girl in the dance
they had them over there five of them
but they had a big tv and me and my
friends would go over there and cook
so i got to learn [__] like that so
prison wasn't all like
me and the [__] longest year i would
have can scraping a [__] thing
you know like i want food [__] no it
wasn't
you know it was something different you
know and i tell you i did acid in there
and [__] and they tested
and all that stuff but it was so weird
that lesson i got in there and i laughed
my ass off i can't tell you
[__]
you know i was joey in there you know we
ran a sports book in there where
50 cents we cooked let me tell you some
of those prison cooks
you [__] that got everything
available to you and can't cook shame on
you
these [__] take the thing out
of an iron and make nachos
[Laughter]
they melt the cheese and they get the
nachos and they [__] they made
burritos
mexicans made burritos in prison
they smuggled potatoes in and green
chilies and
and they sold them for a dollar people
were hustling in the prison and sending
money home to their [__] wives
for their kids it was just amazing to
see and it's funny because i got out
and what do you think i did three months
i got back into selling [__] coke
but i always kept that comedy thing in
mind
and you know people always say like i
want to try comedy i just don't know
what to do
[__] it took me a year to get on stage
i kept writing and lying to people i'm a
comedian it took me a [__] year
but once i got on that [__] stage
it was like all right i'm hooked on the
comedy now i'm still going to be a
criminal
but just like two days a week you know
what i'm saying